they always come back
the killer is a part of something in the
past
this one just feels different
first of all i just have to say as a fan
of the franchise and horror in general
we are so happy to see both of you guys
welcome back to the franchise and so
thank you so much
i think my first question is sort of
like everyone's just looking back on
this series i mean since 1996
so much has changed uh for teens like
when they were watching it compared to
now for you guys what do you think have
been the biggest changes looking back
from when you guys first started to the
kids that are going to be watching it
today and nev i'll start with
well i think i would look to you know
obviously the huge changes in technology
i mean even the differences from the
making of the movies and the writing of
the scripts you know
back in the day we weren't dealing with
cell phones and satellite technology and
social media and all of those things we
didn't have to take into consideration
for the scripts and
as time has changed and technology has
changed that gets added to the script it
makes it more complicated to do a
whodunit but it also makes it more
interesting and that's how we as humans
have changed as well i mean teens are
it's a whole other world now it's a
whole other world that i don't quite
know how to use and i'm trying to figure
it out
[Laughter]
what about you david what do you think
yeah i'd agree with that completely i
mean this new version score and of
amped up there's so many films that they
could reference from the past
and the whole yeah
yeah the whole fandom like the the love
for horror films the talking about it
online
yeah i was gonna say nev i'm sure you've
experienced this since both of you since
the first film came out is just how much
folks love it and especially for sydney
because she's a final girl and i think
anybody and especially with like the
trio if you're the ones that survive it
to the next film you sort of upped the
stakes but i'm just curious for you nev
who's your favorite final girl i mean we
have jamie lee curtis and halloween you
have you know ripley with sigourney
weaver and aliens even your party of
five co-star jennifer love hewitt she's
a final girl from another we did last
summer oh my gosh i mean i love jamie
lee i think she's phenomenal like either
she or sigourney i would have i would
have to say i mean yeah they were the
epic i mean we stacked the deck yeah
yeah for sure
[Laughter]
no and then um david i think what's
really interesting is watching sort of
like dewey's journey in this film and
one of the things that i thought was
interesting was coming back to the role
you made a playlist oh it was a lot of
90s stuff it's just to kind of bring you
back to that sort of time period
oh you can't give me a title i want like
i will spotify it did you have the
fuji's on there
the fuji's album came out when we were
in santa rosa
and we played that non-stop
[Laughter]
such a good album yeah
let me just fantasize one day about like
nev campbell spitting some like lord
hillary i'm just gonna take that
fantasy oh for sure
yes um the last thing i really have to
say is obviously with you guys that have
survived most of these movies if you
could just tell me your real quick
advice for how to survive a scream movie
uh don't go to woods bro that's a really
bad idea do you want to survive
yeah we've decided that and run just run
run run is a good one and maybe just
stay away from sydney prescott because
everyone seems to die around her
i will say someone that's still kind of
mad that jerry o'connell didn't make it
out of that movie i would say that's
probably right i'm sorry it has to be
said
there's certain rules to
surviving the attacks were all on people
related to the original killers
jack melissa congratulations on the film
and on top of just how cool it is to be
in this franchise it's just the legacy
that comes with screams so i want to ask
both of you what was your first
experience with the franchise and jack
i'll start with you i have a kind of
complicated history with scream i i uh
when i was four years old i
trick-or-treated for the first time in
my neighborhood and um
it was the year that the original scream
came out so
i don't think i've ever seen that many
ghost faces in one place and it scared
the hell out of me uh particularly
there's this one ghost face mask that
it's kind of translucent and you can
pump fake blood through it it no i i
still don't like it um but it kind of
swore me off of uh horror movies for for
a very long time and then you know in my
teen years i i started to watch um
you know ease into the horror genre test
my limits i started with stuff like
shawn of the dead and then i got to
scream
and face my fear of ghost face and i
just fell in love with it it's just the
perfect blend of
genuine scares uh humor and meta
commentary and it it lets you
you know it's bringing up all these it's
eliciting uh all these other movies and
talking about horror movies and it makes
you want to go watch them watch things
like halloween friday the 13th
um
i don't know it's just it's just so cool
to be to be a part of this thing so uh
yeah it's a big honor i i was also way
too young to watch scream when they came
out but
when i was like 11 or 12 years old i
became really obsessed with scary movies
and i think that's when i saw the first
three that were out and uh and i was
just like a masochist i still am i
suffer a lot when watching scary movies
but there's an adrenaline rush
of like an accomplishment when you
survive watching a scary movie
and
there's something really amazing about
the balance of the humor and the
and the gore and the
awful kill scenes but then you laugh at
the super witty sarcastic uh very sharp
dialogue in the movie so it almost kind
of balances it out and makes you feel
not as scared in no way now that i'm at
now that i'm older and i and i re-watch
it i'm like this is so smart and yeah it
holds up so i'm just yeah it's an honor
to to join the franchise well it sounds
both of you um are very fond obviously
the scream franchise and so that i think
makes it even harder when you're like
coming in to like join into something
that you already have in high esteem i'm
just curious for you melissa especially
there's that but like did the added
courtney cox of it all like i heard
you're like
a massive friends fan like did that like
really push it over the edge
girl like you don't even know jack knows
and he was with me all the time
it was when's courtney getting here like
i was courtney i played the scenario of
me being meeting courtney a million ways
in my brain
and i was like what am i gonna say like
am i gonna hug her am i gonna tell her
much i love her am i gonna try and play
cool
uh i want her to like not hate me um is
she going to be nice is she going to be
awful you know they say don't meet your
heroes because they can't disappoint you
courtney is the
sweetest
nicest most generous talented person you
can ever meet like she exceeds all your
expectations and she was so nice and
it was it's just incredible i still
can't believe it
if i can just
watching the arc of melissa like like
waiting for courtney to arrive and then
and then when she actually did arrive
and then seeing the two of them become
best friends it was the most wholesome
thing i've ever seen in my life
it's incredible
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is gonna keep coming for
you
you ready for this
never i think like the first thing i
definitely want to ask is like you guys
did such a great job of the mother-son
relationship uh what was like
challenging about having to do that
under such crazy circumstances as like
literally a masked person stabbing
everyone yeah i'll start with you marley
you kind of have to just be oblivious to
the
the ghost face aspect when you're it was
really quite frankly easy to establish
our relationship because
dylan's such an awesome actor and person
um
i it was just
i don't know it was effortless that part
of it yes
and same compliments tomorrow the
obvious
awesome well both of you did such a
great job dylan this is not your first
time to sort of uh i would say dabble in
very well known
franchise type horror
but what would you say are you like a
horror fan are you specifically drawn to
this genre
yes
yes to both
i'm drawn to it i'm i i love to go to
all the new horror movies that come out
um i'm all about it which is why it's
crazy for me to be in this franchise now
yeah and named literally after wes
craven like did you when did they let
you in on on that sort of homage in your
name i feel like i should have realized
right away but i didn't it somehow took
me
weeks to even like compute someone
pointed it out and i was like oh my of
course you're right like that's crazy
um and yeah it's like a subtle nod but
nonetheless it's um
it i'm involved in a nod to wes craven
and that feels
so special i mean does judy get any
credit for naming her son i
i mean i i was just about to say i was
just about to say i don't want to and
not only for you but coming back from
previous installments how does it feel
coming back knowing this film would have
been dedicated to him i think he would
be very proud of of this offering a lot
of care was was taken to do right by
wes's world the universe the scream
universe that he created it's so
groundbreaking and tonally so unique
by being self-referencing and funny and
yet absolutely terrifying at the same
time
so i think i think we did him proud
oh i definitely say and then also like i
feel bad because like after you've
watched so many of them like they kind
of in your head run a little bit
together but that's when i do feel is
very different so i'm gonna ask you
what you think about this one that
really sort of sets it apart among every
other entry in the franchise first of
all we're you know we're taking it back
towards woodsborough so that's very much
a character and there's there's some
great tie-ins and some great backstory
and history that obviously i won't spoil
but that is a big element i think what
sets it apart as well is that this is i
think very much so a direct callback to
the first one in a lot of ways
um and
it is a relaunch of the franchise and it
feels like that too it feels like sort
of bringing it back and also starting
fresh so it's uh yeah it feels like
we're starting you know hopefully the
beginning of um
something new and like a revival of this
kind of like you know patting your head
and rubbing your stomach at the same
time like you're
paying homage and yet we're relaunching
and it's fresh and new and slightly
different i i think the main thing is
like just chronologically like a lot of
time has passed in
in the storytelling you know like
yeah um in the plot it's a series
characters in a different exactly yeah
as far as like the three og characters
um you know never courtney and david
like we've been following them through
every movie and they have been the leads
of all of the movies so far whereas
they they're huge parts of this film but
the new leads are this young cast and
that hasn't necessarily been the case
for the other screen movies so i think
that also sets us apart as well or it
feels like we're getting invested in new
characters like really invested for the
first time um in terms of new like young
teens in town so so yeah whatever his
link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
if this is all i have to do for today
that's it we're good like like that's it
then this interview is the only downhill
from there but i'm gonna try and keep it
to that level
jasmine i want to talk to you about it
because your character is not giving too
much away to say she's very
knowledgeable about horror movies she is
the quote-unquote expert as it were and
i'm just curious like i have a feeling
like if you're going to be the expert
you have to go on a deep dive so did you
go on like a horror movie deep dive
i
i swam in the horror movie pool
but i was able to find that passion from
my own nerding out abilities which for
me are broadway and the enneagram the
second we got to wilmington i made the
entire cast and the directors and the
producers each take the enneagram quiz i
needed to know who was what
and so i just um approached the
monologue as if i was talking about the
things that i nerded out about
that's right i love that so let me just
real quick since you mentioned broadway
i guess you are voting for a scream
musical like would you be down for that
yeah and are you kidding me which part
do you want to play i mean well it
depends if it's like a version a new
version with new characters or if it's
based on the characters that are already
here because obviously i'd want to be
mindy otherwise i think we need a black
sydney let's be real you would knock
that out of the park
i don't know what i gotta do to see that
happen but i'll petition as a bunch of
fake names or something and manuel i'm
here
lin manuel would eat that scream the
musical and then not pull down
and i already have a connection through
melissa
yes get it done and one of his favorite
musicals is the heather's musical and
he's another likes are you a broadway
nerd too
yeah let's get it girl we need to go see
company with patti lupone right now you
know i'm ready i'm about to go to new
york just to see the ah let's see it
together
i i've gotta like take the pages lives
are gonna get mad at me because i feel
like mason we're going into broadway but
the [ __ ] is like yours you guys are
like
yeah like this is your your beat though
because
correct me if i'm wrong the internet
lies all the time did you write an essay
about screen i i did indeed in in my uh
sophomore year of college and to be
entirely honest i didn't know i'd have
to answer for it five years
i got i say a minus to be entirely
honest i don't know i bet he got an a i
can guarantee without looking too far
into it i probably wrote it the night
before it was due but he's got that good
brain that's right and coffee
well did you have to use that brain for
the script because i heard they kept
y'all guessing like i heard like they
never told y'all who the killer was not
until the last like when did they ever
tell you mason i'll start with you like
when did you did you when did you know
it was it was a bit of a game of
deception where i feel like we would
make our guesses and plead our cases for
our theories and they would always
say yes they would be like yeah that's
right you actually you you got it you
were the one that got it you'd leave
feeling great only to film the next day
and be like those [ __ ] he lied
to me that's okay but that created an
error that no matter what happens
everyone could be the killer everyone is
a suspect which led well to the filming
the scenes because then we we really
didn't know we weren't just acting we
were
smacking to be entirely honest i don't
even know now uh you know something's
over i i just uh no idea that's right it
could be you
i i actually saw somewhere online that
it was you funnel that off you are
wearing red
i i mean listen i'm not saying that i
did not have the tendency to want to
murder my town at one point in my
teenage years but nobody made a movie
who didn't real quick though since we
already went on the like singing diet so
did y'all karaoke because it seems like
there's a lot of musical theater nerds
in this cast and just like people are
like
karaoke but we would sing we all okay
jenna ortega has the best music taste
you also have good music today sodas
dylan mine's gotten better it wasn't
great at the time it's gotten better
well there is a lot of jasmine is an
incredible musician uh and song
singer-songwriter song comes out this
month
dylan monette is obviously part of the
incredible band
sonia sonia is an amazing singer i think
she goes by sonia amar yeah i think so i
think she just goes by sonia listen
everyone sings jack even plays guitar
insane melissa was in the heights and
malicious great i've seen this movie
before
not this movie i think i'd have to ask
both of you because i don't even want to
age myself to say where i was when i saw
it but what was your first memory of
scream and mikey i'll start with you uh
well i for some reason i i think just
growing up i've always known what scream
is and i've always
recognized the ghost face mask but i
really only saw the movie just a few
years ago for the first time but um
since then i've i've seen it uh
a few times in
the rest of the movies as well yeah yeah
you got to get the whole franchise
eventually sonya what about you what was
your first memory of scream
my first memory of scream was
seeing the first film when i was way too
young to watch it was like eight and
i was terrified and i was kind of like
forced into it by my older siblings to
watch it
but even before i had watched it i you
know i recognized ghost's face and seen
you know like the
figure and the mask and you know it's it
it goes out in like pop culture history
and is iconic so
yeah it's got the best branding like
it's like mcdonald's ghost face it's
like recognizable branding for it um i
guess it goes without saying if you're
going to join a movie like scream you're
going to have to show your scream-worthy
talents
but i'm just curious uh mikey who do you
think has the best scream
among the cast members
i think jenna has a really good high pet
high pitched like blood curdling one
uh-huh okay i'll i'll give jenna my vote
yeah i mean all right so you hear her
scream and she's it's insane yeah she's
so yeah this is true let's just try to
remember this and i guess that's just
seen in that scream it's like
you've got
so that's your your favorite too i like
jenna's
this little missy has a great scream
um
i feel like everyone has
their own
i don't know
yeah well what's the secret to a great
scream like how do you put yourself in
the mindset to really like cry out like
that because it has to appear
like it's spontaneous but it's not so
like as to scream queens what is the
secret somebody's got to tell me because
i feel like i have a terrible scream
i yeah i need i need some tips so it's
great mikey strange thing though because
it's not something that you practice a
lot and you're like okay i have to
scream and i don't know what it's going
to sound like but some sound is going to
come out yeah yeah like when you're in a
scene and you're in it it probably is
easier but i feel like i remember we
were doing press photos and they wanted
like shots of us just like screaming and
they're like just screaming i'm like
there's like people watching you and
you're just there and you're like like
what do i do
that's like an awkward moment i'm like i
don't know how to scream but when it's
in in context
easier i think
you